what's up reject nation we're gonna
watch cobra kai
season three episode four today if you
can go ahead subscribe click that
notification bell to get notified when
our next reaction is nothing to be very
much appreciated also hit that like
button thumbs up yeah
guys as per use gotta mention that this
is youtube so reaction highlights only
full-length reaction watch-alongs are
you single with the time code are all
over at our patreon page
we're over there we cover a lot of [ __ ]
so much [ __ ] and
so many other shows my goodness my
goodness
look at that okay patreon plug
complete thank you to everyone who's
been joining
means a hell of a lot to have you be a
patron jack your support
means the world
love you all learn to embrace
the silence learn to be intimate with
the audience
which is why we have sold more cars in
the past 10 years than any other dealer
in the san fernando valley
unfortunately we have already made our
decision
i'm sorry to say the wheels are already
in motion the wheels
he's like the italian representative of
all of karate
i'm coming home with a yes don't worry i
know you are that's a salesman
the hell am i gonna do he's probably
gonna cheat on his wife
really make daniel unlikable this season
is that the friend of yours best friend
i've read are you visiting him while you
are in town
i wish ah you could go to the okinawa
village
in japan you can always visit someone
even when they are gone that's stupid
like a zombie
you always have to stay one step ahead
of him that's the only way to guarantee
a victory
is that understood that's how i beat
youtube
i want you to kick this tree off the top
red you stuck
oh ripped pants
can you do a crease whoa oh
not this is a valiant attempt
don't you want a running start don't
need one
you don't win by finding shortcuts diana
but you have to fight
smart sweep the leg johnny
and you always come out on time until
somebody knocks you off the pole
and then we start all over
who had their phone out during class can
i turn on the tv for you get you another
pillow
sorry bobby i screwed up just tell
robbie i'll make things right
that'll do it is he doing okay he's
awake
a little out of it but healing is this
the same day
yeah johnny looks way better i can take
you in there if you like
i'm sure he'd love to see you oh there's
all the last step episode
japanese escalators are very different
oh how excited he is turning this
business trip into a leisure one how are
we danny
well last time you see tommy bridge
it'll still be military run
it turns out that the deed never went
back to the people
sato is still just a ruling with an iron
fist
so you didn't even watch the movie
they're really good at reminding you of
any piece of context
he remembers karate kid 2 very well
no what oh no what
no kfc forever 21
baskin robbins gap oh red lobster ugh
you ruined karate kid too come on
where's that group of kids who are going
to gang up on it
hello son hey robbie we're holding up
the line
don't let me throw a shoe at you is she
from the previous seasons that's ally
it's the easter egg it's elizabeth
self go
hey dad i'm glad you showed up
you ready to rock our earth science
presentation
my popularity is on the rise well yours
is steadily declining
maybe we can meet in the middle like a
sexual venn diagram
very nice smooth
not bad oh just look at this you look a
little turned on lady
would you say sexual venn wadogram hey
22 in a row new record whatsoever
you knew it and at 8 251 individual
pieces this meticulously assembled
oh
dimitri you get in there it took me
three
weeks to build i took my ball three
seconds to destroy less than that
actually huh do you have another one do
you have another one
better back off or you won't be lucky oh
here we go here we go
why don't you go sleep around with
someone new and break his heart
miss larusso you know our new guidelines
against physical contact
now hug him did she enter your personal
bubble without your verbal consent
yeah she definitely triggered me in my
safe space probably shouldn't bring your
toys to school anyway it's not a toy
it's a science project
no space is safe i want to be more like
hawk
that's the message of this show i want
to be aisha out by season three where is
she
look at all these american companies
this is great this is the dream
what happened to the villagers why are
they upset about what happened to their
home
it saved the village what about like
tsunamis
insurance must be crazy jersey mike's
jersey mike's in months is is there a
dance academy here now
guess who the teacher is oh hey look the
us military is also around us that's
exactly what your wife wants for you to
rekindle with your ex-girlfriend
[Music]
she looks so different but i can't
figure out what it is
i love that they got her back in the
show before hallie this is who the fans
really want us
all right
oh daniel's son we haven't heard of me
call that in so long
i know
[Music]
you might as well well you're my kid and
i'm your dad
so let me give you a hand i'll start
being a dad on the restricted hours i
can see you
here at this soup kitchen we have one
good day
over a month ago and where have you been
since then miguel
the kid who's back you bro well i'm sure
miguel appreciates that hey i'm not
[Music]
[ __ ] larussos
of course they're standing right there
those [ __ ]
i hate them come on have a little school
spirit oh yeah
go mountain lion oh she gonna start
getting into demetri now oh yeah
that's what i'm talking about baby it's
the mystery season
i think we're doormats let's prove them
wrong let's do a montage
damn damn extreme
soccer
he's so ridiculous she loved you you
know man you had a good thing going
oh
headbutt
wow
[Music]
enough shaolin soccer they managed to
have a secret karate fight i got to see
the cranberries open for radiohead wow
1990 wow zombie linga
and dream wow oh rest in peace
auntie okay got sick i was sorry to hear
she passed
i know she's very proud of you i don't
remember her
[Laughter]
i stayed uh what was your word for it
three ages yeah i'm supposed to believe
that a guy never got a ring on that
finger
this is when he cheats he's a half a
world away
it's a hard to find
he's flirting i feel like i haven't seen
you in five minutes but it's
been 30 years it doesn't look like it's
been five minutes guys
[Music]
maybe if we had the facebook and
instagram back then we would have never
lost that
probably wouldn't have been good for his
current relationship yeah no
i think things would have been a lot
more complicated if he had those back
then
why did you really come back oh she
knows him
leave your wife daniel i am the same age
now that mr miyagi was
when he met me i wish he could be here
to help guide him
i think i can make that happen he's
alive in japan
people aren't gone is there a miyagi
hologram
of miyagi something more spiritual
oh damn petty in water
oh let me get a chicken sandwich and he
even orders it like a cup
give me three minutes you got three
minutes
you're in a bad place and i probably put
you there
probably i never wanted to hurt you
because i care about those kinds of
things
then you start leading those kids down
the wrong path and then got picked up by
netflix
and there's only one way to get you out
of this [ __ ] the wheel fist
hmm when a boy comes back
we'll help him get up on his feet uh
go anywhere near miguel or his family
and i'll kill you oh the only thing he
said
the entire time looks like my time is up
you know for a hot second there almost
believed his manipulative ways
look oh great there goes another blemish
on my permanent record this is
[ __ ] ms larouche i think you need
two weekends of rehabilitative detention
oh you uh school sucks i
i don't know her that well oh dimitri i
just don't have the heart
to sell it i can relax
so many letters oh very romantically
mr miyagi wrote love letters you're
surprised yes
are you kidding how can you not imagine
i could imagine me out here
absolutely i got to fall in love with
you
twice in one lifetime
don't do this daniel and now i'm
actually worried
i was making jokes earlier now no
worries he's gonna slip up
[Music]
there is nothing to do except watch
tv and think think about
where i have been thinking about where
i am going
i have always looked for signs to show
me
the right way that i got lost
until i knocked down myself oh no oh
my god
[Music]
loyalty and love for those around him
is a guiding light to me oh
the man he has become oh
he still hasn't
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
daniel-san has welcomed me into his
phone oh [ __ ]
and he has passed on what i teach him
samantha makes me feel like i'm hurt on
me
oh
what the [ __ ] happening
eat these people not the signs
that guide us back do you like that
nikki
i heard that in a car commercial
one of daniels thank you
what are you doing here want the phone
yes
go get it nothing that's not gonna work
even with the surgery i might never be
able to go ahead
you're dead out of that bed and do
something
that's unexpected i'm always gonna be
right here next to you because i'll
always be your teacher
oh yeah johnny
go get it listen
yeah yes come on
oh no here comes a joke
that's right you feel like a champ
nurse
[Laughter]
kane you got to visit her who is it
oh no yep
son of a [ __ ]
oh hell yeah back to the the ice
breaking
i was misleading that's what we call an
easter egg in these parts
hearing those letters last night it was
like i was back with mr miyagi
you've got to move in with my family put
good out in the world
and good will come back to you
what a load of crap
it will work out i know it will i hope
so
will man you got two more seasons on
netflix man
oh oh [ __ ] back of the hand touch
you know what that leads to daniel
and i
[Music]
[Applause]
oh is he gonna fight him i don't know
he's gonna have exactly satos
this is gonna be yeah
i'm a car dealer now well then we'll
destroy all the cars
the show's so fascinating
i'm very touched it's a very fascinating
show
very fascinating it's just so funny to
go back to the
first couple karate kids movies and to
see that not much has changed
let's see yeah see how far we'll come
but how familiar a lot of the
it's positive thinking and bullying
positive bullying
two venn diagrams of the karate kid song
people who
care at all for just humanity versus the
straw
who only care for strong things yeah man
i mean although with robbie in uh juvie
it makes sense there'd be some bullies
yeah yeah that lends itself to that
dynamic
i'd imagine so it's a little less over
the top
in juvie i feel like whereas like
certain times you'll cut
and not always in this show just i feel
like in general with school bullies
you'll cut to a school scene and i'll be
like this seems like it
would play better in a juvie scenario
but these
juvie bullies are exactly like all the
other bullies outside of juventus
they're really no different you could
just pluck them into the school and it
would be the same scenario
yeah oh man it is another great episode
this is really good man i like the way
they handle their flashbacks a lot
because it's like when daniel first
starts
he's going through japan and you know
part of my brain's going
when you go to the okinawa village what
do you do that and then as he's
reminiscing he has like this
exaggerated sense of memory and wonder
watching out the car window
yeah okinawa oh how peaceful it was
and and they're really letting you like
rest into the memories
of karate kid too and then they show up
and it's
consumerism you know it's it's
gentrified yeah developed and heads you
know you could argue that some of the
soul has been taken out
but at the same time i like that it
seemed that it benefited them
even for kumiko kumiko yeah
yeah because it seems like i'm going to
say it wrong later on yeah
preparing myself just throw in any
japanese name
so when jin kazama shows him yeah
i mean for her like she wasn't resentful
towards the whole thing at all
no like she was very positive about it
so i like that it didn't become about
that then this
really would have steered off course
into a completely different show
that it's the sequel to karate kid yeah
just him coming back and like
man this sounds really changed it's not
the way i remembered it back when i was
young yeah
so doing that but then when chosen shows
up
mm-hmm chosen chosen yeah with a zed i
don't know why i'm i'm doubting my names
so much so when chosen shows up and how
it becomes like this
race of memories of all the bullying
that he did
and really that is the reasons
this is everything right here he was the
hawk of karateka
you get the flashes there but the way
they handled the flashbacks whereas at
times i felt in previous seasons
it's like they're cut into it for the
audience it really plays like a memory
here
for danny like the way the flashes go
upon seeing him
like oh yeah that is how it would
probably race in its own
traumatized brain from from all that
but it's exciting you know and i i think
they have really good chemistry
still absolutely better than it was in
karate kid too why not argue
yeah and like especially giving them
such an emotional moment to
pin the heart of the episode to like it
really it's weird like yeah it made me
nostalgic for it but at the same time i
was like yeah you know
like they are really really nice in the
modern day chemistry that they have
together like she just illuminated
the screen and i mean i enjoyed their
relationship in karate kid too but yeah
coming back here and especially just
with how
touching i guess and sweet that scene
was with the letters
yeah i really think they've done a nice
job of
taking that history taking those
flashbacks and yeah making it all
feel like i mean of course half of it
your mind is like of course for the
audience and the people who didn't see
those movies ever this will help but
also yeah it does kind of make
the mythology and the story as it's
happened up until now feel like a living
thing and feel like something that you
know it's like
a lot of people endeared to and lived
through and grew up with and now coming
back after so long for the people who
already know the older karate kid stuff
like i feel
like it avoids being gimmicky or being
lazy in using those things because you
know they really
tapped back into that sense of earnest
heart that i feel like is part of what
makes the original films work
because like going back to karate kid
too i was like oh dang like we're we're
gonna just spend a lot of time like i
feel like in a more modern movie we
would
like find a lot of reasons to skip to
the fighting but like there's a lot of
just like character story going on in
that movie so then when the fights
happen
you know they stand out more yeah and
that movie is jam-packed with fights
absolutely so many fights every five
minutes like when am i gonna fight you
santo i just can't wait to
i think too with like with those two
actors and the fact that yes they're
much older now they've had a lot of
experience in their own personal lives
as actors
so along with bringing that experience
and wisdom and you
feel that these characters have lived
such a journey i thought it just felt so
authentic
where people just know each other like
he has okay to pinpoint it down he has
that line
i haven't seen you in 30 years but it
feels like it's been five minutes
and the way their scene is played it
does feel that way
in a very authentic way i really
appreciated that and then also yeah
getting some more of that wisdom from mr
miyagi
car dealership quote about uh people
guide you
and also you know to get good things you
got to put good out there it's funny you
know like a lot of the thought process
and stuff especially i was thinking
about miguel
who who feels like he might not be able
to walk i'm like you guys are talking a
lot about a little documentary called
the secret
that's all i'm gonna say a lot of the
solutions
and some of the things you guys are
getting thrown your way for answers
it's on that documentary works
wonders i think mr miyagi would have
very much support i don't know about
crease but i think miyagi would have
very much
liked the secret i mean i could see
chris getting on board with it
if you just toughen it up a little bit
you know all you think of are tough
thoughts you'll attract a tough life to
yourself
yeah getting back to japan it looks like
they really shot it there which is good
yeah i'm gonna say and i would be
curious to know if they
if they did or if they just got
establishing shots and then swapped
stuff in
because it felt authentic and that's a
nice thing it looked very real
yeah and i mean just like some of the
big rewarding moments would have to be
you know johnny and miguel it's just so
i feel bad for johnny
like he doesn't have a school he doesn't
have a son i thought he didn't have
miguel but i just got miguel back and
that was such a
that was such a rewarding moment like i
i thought it was going to play out
longer
when he moves the the phone away yeah
then he just goes like
it goes back to that it's so unexpected
i adore that sound he makes it's just so
funny every time he ever does it
and then you're back then he does it in
the hospital
this is so funny i wonder what the world
outside of the
people who do karate view this like
there's a bunch of other arms cross
going these guys take karate
way too short acting like this
and all be all right here is karate yeah
like they're going to be thrust out into
the streets to fend for themselves
without nothing but their fists and
their wherewithal
any time yeah i love it it's so fun
we'll get bogged down predictions but
where are we at right now with the
series we got
crease trying to court johnny and then i
think he and then now he's
gordon robbie it's like oh god what a
brutal game
that guy is such an [ __ ] like man
they have really
really known how to make him a villain
yeah
like he's just he's like a hardcore
narcissistic abusive [ __ ] in
in the movies like he's ridiculous and
then here
he has like these more insidious ways of
just
like he is this that's what i think
they've done with him they've made him
the cobra
yeah he's the snake who's just lurking
through everything
you know i mean especially off the last
season the way he endears himself and he
even plays
you know he'll dial up his personability
and
moments to appeal especially to johnny i
was worried
in in that moment but i'm glad that
obviously johnny didn't go for it but
for a second there yeah i think you even
pointed it out like ah he's putting on
that thing of like oh maybe this guy
does have a sense of reason somewhere
but but
no no he doesn't and i and i like the
way how who's the actor that plays
johnny again
william zobka william zobka i like the
way he he did his performance
uh because you can feel that this was
his father figure growing up and there's
always this sense of wanting to put his
guard down
but no but he's learning not to i really
feel like johnny's really evolving to
like a good guy
you know yeah i mean he tries as fast
like he's just a good guy with a temper
now
you know yeah i mean he's still got a
bit of his boyish attitude but he's
definitely learned
like a moral compass in this whole
series yeah
and i think the guy who plays robbie
like his acting is
so much better his acting was i don't
really like him in the first season
and i thought he did really good in the
second season and i feel like he's just
way
he he just gets better and better like
this was part of the classic of the co
of cobra kiva series
of i'm trying to make things around my
son i can't but i managed to make things
rap at miguel there's a jealousy there
and it is more of a conflicting
convoluted situation now because
miguel's in the hospital because of what
robbie did yeah
you know robbie's future became a future
like it's
it's all craziness for him but there's
also with how this show
hones in so much on like sins of the
father and trying not to repeat
demons from the past and stuff like that
or inherit demons
like i love the look i don't know how
much it was intentional but something i
picked up on
because i'm deep so deep deep
it's when uh they're at the community
service thing
and it's like he's behind there he's a
prisoner and he's doing his community
service and he's looking across from him
and there's this look that he just that
the actor plays robbie gives
his dad in that moment of
i don't even know what to how to
interpret it there's just so much of
that look that was feeling like he
maybe he's thinking i could be down that
path i could end up like my father or my
father is just trying to do the right
thing
like he's a kid and he's in jail doing
community service now
and there's his dad who is repeating a
lot of the mistakes that his dad might
have made too
so it i like the mirroring image that
they were doing there
didn't really rely on dialogue which i
thought was interesting like that's what
i mean there's interpretation to be had
and also the really fun stuff was a
school dude this is dimitri
season this is the look all right we got
a lot of crazy [ __ ] going on
i'm happy miguel's back with johnny
happy all this is going
there's exciting stuff happening this is
where i'm kind of confused this stuff
was chosen
yeah how's that going to link back to
everything at home
is he gonna learn something and then
that's gonna he's gonna take that
learning philosophy and take it there's
he has something to do with the car
dealerships you know
he works at doyona he's not gonna he's
gonna be the guy who signed that
agreement i'm wondering if they're
like that the village went corporate and
perhaps there was some deal you know
absolutely see it like if you beat me in
a fight
i will give you some deal
you know that's what i mean i'm
wondering where that's going otherwise
i'm like this seems like such a sidestep
story
yeah it would almost to me seem like i
would expect maybe them to do something
yeah that does parallel the sato and
miyagi
rivalry in the original karate kid 2
or something because you know that also
had an example of like oh
you've been away for so long and now
you're back and we gotta settle this and
i'm not gonna let you leave until we
settle this and i could definitely
imagine that happening here especially
because we gave a whole episode at least
in danny's context to kumiko
and i have to imagine that the next
episode for danny is going to be mostly
about chosen
yeah yeah oh boy there's a lot to
uncover here
and also the school stuff is a lot of
fun yeah man shaolin soccer
i mean they weren't they didn't have the
miyagi doe attitude about it
no they it's about the fact sam's a
little bit of a cobra
yeah she's i she's at her wits and she's
upset
and i yeah i am curious as to how
they're gonna develop that too because
for them it just seems like this problem
is ongoing like this is the problem of
this episode that gets the least
development other than escalation it's
just getting worse
you know i just think that principal is
the stupidest
woman i like how blind could you be
yeah how blind like how blind could you
be
look i'm not trying to stereotype here i
totally am
that guy has a mohawk and it's bright
red
and someone in this faculty must have
noticed his
full back tattoo at some point you would
think as well as i don't know clearly
signs of
been being an [ __ ] all the time yeah
like he can't put on that like
oh safe space voice like with an eye and
earshot of every single teacher so yeah
yeah i am curious as to why that we
don't get any sort of
entertainment from the principal when
their side just comes out from talking
to them at least in the way that scene
is staged
and they're just like well the cobras
told me everything you guys are in
trouble
yeah yeah it seems like a bigger problem
than one set of kids or another so the
first of all
that's right that's what the twist is
gonna be and this is all her plan
originally
she never died no she became a principal
west valley high
yeah she was her insanity kept her going
for so long
and then chris will come to each of the
school in season four but that's that
scene was a blast
that was a blasty blast of a scene yeah
and a creative way to
infuse a fight scene all right guys
well thank you so much for being here
hey
ah hey do you prefer amanda or kumiko
why choose one daniel isn't
nope subscribe click that notification
bell hit that like button last but not
least aniso liva
it just doesn't get better
than anissa oliva nope anisa
now that you're being vaccinated it's
time
time for john to reignite the flame
of the gas station love it's time for
john to travel to texas
to meet you at the gas station and for
you to say
hi to his cobra oh
and he's going to go hello
you a niece dirty girl
you filthy filthy filth
in all sincerity and nisa you're a nasty
woman
yeah but more importantly you're a
pervert
i think you are sensational
and 2021 i think is going to be worse
for you than 2020.
you know why because now you get the
vaccine
how fun can it really be when you're not
living in panic and worry all the time
about your own well-being
you might get bored you get really bored
yeah and now you have no excuse to
not socialize with people so i feel like
it's
it's a big mistake it's gonna be rough
it's a big mistake getting that vaccine
i'm sorry
that you're vaccinated yeah leticia
wright would be
very disappointed in you oh yeah she
can't meet us at the gas station i
already let her know
in fact i'm gonna catch it before i get
there just to test out your immunity so
be prepared for that
all right this is science and love
and that's what we call chemistry
don't you dare cut that
[Music]
you